il signifie que new du bal au cinéma
arabe vis à vis de la base de l'année
recommence
l'appareil transporte m
les préconisations qui seront sûrement
nécessaires pour que lorsque un train de
pneus explose on ne se trouve pas
demande tel enchaînement et bien
impliqueront qu'il y ait des travaux
qu'ils soient faits sur nantes pour à
nouveau dix on remettra en service
certificat de navigabilité donc du vent
de concours
on trouve que ça fait beaucoup tant que
l'avion était immobilisé plus ça
attendra et plus ça sera dur de remettre
l'avion en vol qui plus est là
maintenant ça s'accélère on part sur des
décisions officielles avec traque
certificat de navigabilité qui sont
hyper lourd de conséquences
derrière puisque pour le retrouver le
certificat de navigabilité ça engendrera
des manifs qui en supportera le coût est
ce que ça vaut le coup au niveau de
l'exploitation de l'avion je sais pas
ceci ne signifie pas que l'enquêté
terminée l'enquêté loin d'être terminée
il ya encore beaucoup de travail à faire
beaucoup de travail pour comprendre ce
qui s'est passé en détail accumuler de
nouveaux éléments
donc il est serait prématuré d'anticiper
que ce soit sur les faits qui sont
attendues encore ou sur les conclusions
de l'enquêté